liberals doubling down on their awful
horrendous anti-police policies because
they're terrible that's what they do
even after historic crime surge in
violent crime in austin texas if your
life is in an immediate danger or a
crime is no longer in progress residents
are being told to no longer call 9-1-1
they're being told to call 3-1-1
we are experiencing staffing shortages
many times people do have to wait on
hold uh when they're calling 3-1-1 and
we're just going to be working the best
that we can
given uh the circumstances that we have
uh regarding staffing this is crazy and
while crime rages in new york city mayor
bill de blasio is rolling out a new
initiative to hire greeters at precincts
doctor's customer service go around the
table dagon um customer service you know
you know crime stopping i thought was
number one but uh apparently now they're
focused on other things like christmas
greeters and stuff these are more tales
from the left-wing looniverse down in
austin texas or excuse me the people's
republic of austin i think most people
in texas would be happy if they strapped
air balloons to that city and hope it
floated somewhere to the northeast
and then there's new york city the big
apple or as we refer to it hell on earth
but this is all related to liberal
policies of coddling the criminals
of
vilifying the cops and then the victims
what victims they're just
tossed away like garbage like detroit us
if you're and just question if you're
if your car is carjacked you're staying
on the side of the road do you call
311 living in a liberal city is having
the family conversation of if i get
attacked what do i do if i see somebody
in the street getting attacked what do i
do because there's nobody there to to be
that has your back like i'm thinking
about carrying a hockey stick down the
street just so that works yeah i'm not
joking like i every every day i see
dangerous
mentally ill people in the street
chasing people every day i just pretend
i'm
mentally ill myself and people generally
leave me alone some liberals would argue
i am baby rich so richard um you know
listen i find the real systemic racism
being that i was a cop in it
overwhelmingly minority community black
and hispanic eastern new york brooklyn
um the real systemic racism is divorcing
them from policing where they get preyed
on by lunatics and animals every day um
and they would come out and tap me on
the shoulder and like beg us to do
something but say please don't say
anything i think that's the real
systemic rate i think liberal liberalism
itself is systemically racist your
thoughts on that isn't liberal uh well i
think that's a very loaded question um
but let's actually have a conversation
around how we make policing better in
this country right because i think
that's what we're all trying to strive
for at this table i agree and so what we
saw over the past couple of months was
we saw democrats and republicans try to
come together and get the george ford
policing act done they had everybody at
the table they had the police unions at
the table they had black lives matter at
the table and they were making progress
uh recently we know those talks fell
apart um the police union came out this
week and they said here's why they
thought that they were actually thought
the talk's very productive and they're
like this these bills were going to give
us more money they were going to give us
the ability to reform our police
departments they were going to give us
the ability to create a universal
standard on how we do policing around
the country unfortunately tim scott
walked away from that and that's really
sad because we could actually have
gotten something done for this country
that would make crime go down and also
make people trust police more because
the problem that we have in black
communities to your point don
is that dan scott
i guess
the the problem that we have is that
there is a breakdown in trust and
there's a breakdown in communication
between policing police and communities
of color and so yes police communities
want police to be there to stop crime
but they also often times don't trust
the police at night and various times so
we've got to figure out a way to bridge
that divide and this bill was a step in
the right direction to do that okay well
richard you wanted to have a
conversation about improving policing we
did have that conversation last year and
you guys decided to defund the police no
we didn't that's what they did in austin
texas they defunded seattle the police
to the tune of
richard 150 million dollars was slashed
out of the police budget it was the
biggest defunding of any city in the
country they're short 400 officers
that's why there's a crime surge that's
why they have 60 murders so far in
austin that's why it's a 60-year high in
austin texas that's why last year a 911
call averaged seven minutes and this
year it averages nine minutes a lot can
happen in two minutes you should know
that so when you talk about oh you're
not gonna do anything except to fund the
police and when you have your house
broken into they steal the safe they
jack your car you're going to call
someone who's coming a guy like you in a
suit was going to come write something
down okay so what else did they take
that doesn't make people feel safe
richard don't you want to feel safe yeah
but i want you to feel sick but to be
clear i'm not defending please i'm for
defunding bad police officers
kennedy i know you have something i
don't disagree with that i think that
that we have to make it easier to get
rid of the bad cops who are oftentimes
protected by police unions
uh 99 of the police officers out there
who wear the badge and do the job
they're good people who want to protect
citizens and make life better they want
to apprehend bad guys and and do a good
job the bad ones give the good ones a
really bad name and that that is one of
the issues that i have and i think
that's a conversation we can have in
terms of criminal justice reform uh this
just in some breaking news dan texas has
voted to it's gone he kicked austin out
of the states okay so austin is no
longer part of texas really so that's
what it is that's awesome did we give it
to mexico no austin is its own country
city state like athens university
yes exactly okay so so they're gonna
figure out their own way in closing real
quick the reason there's that distrust
in the black community is precisely
because of black lives matter telling
people police are hunting black men i've
been in those rooms nobody's hunting
black men trust me and guess who those
communities voted for for new york city
mayor
a black former police officer
up next the surge at the border be
damned what the biden administration is
doing that will turn the crisis into a
catastrophe hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else